I cut gray an acting returning officer
at the election of a member of
parliament for the Copeland constituency
held on Thursday the 8th of June 2017
declare that the number of votes for
each candidate at the said election is
as follows Crossman herbert Winfred UK
Independence Party 1094 Hansen Rebecca
Charlotte Liberal Democrats 1404
Harrison Trudi Lynn the Conservative
Party 20 1062 trottin Gillian Ruth
Labour Party 19,000 367 the number of
ballot papers rejected was as follows
want earn official mark zero voting for
more than one candidate 12 writing on
mark by which the voter could be
identified three being unmarked or
wholly void for uncertainty seventy the
total number of ballot papers being 85
and I do hereby declare that Trudy Lynn
Harrison is duly elected as Member of
Parliament for the Copeland constituency
[Applause]
thank you firstly I'd like to pay my
fans to the returning officer mrs. Pat
Graham and my opponents for their clean
and positive campaign this is a
significant victory as until the 23rd of
February this year Copeland had held a
Labour Member of Parliament since 1935
to win two elections so close together
is even more remarkable I would like to
thank thank my family friends local
Association and the many volunteers who
joined the campaign we have visited
towns and villages across the
constituency and it has been my absolute
pleasure to speak with so many of you
and of course I would like to thank the
thousands of people who put their faith
in me once again and also those who
didn't vote for me this time to reassure
them that I will work hard as a member
of parliament for Copeland this is a
victory for the party that is on the
side of ordinary working people which
will respect the way we voted in the
referendum and those negotiations which
will commence in just 10 days I will
work hard for each and every one of my
constituents on the key issues that
really matter
nuclear industry jobs health education
technical fills road rail and digital
connectivity flood resilience and making
sure that we get the best deal for
brexit in Copland
thank you
[Applause]